hi Kevin my question is what should I do
with the 21,000 in my bank count I'm
only 20 and I have 21,000 because of a
parent passing away when I was younger
well it's definitely time for another
session of ask mr. wonderful I got
dozens of fantastic questions from you
so let's get right at it and I was
wondering if you had any thoughts on how
I should invest it and grow it so that I
have a nice-sized savings account after
college also what's your opinion on
insurance Messrs the rates vary but you
can't lose money thanks for your time
and have a great day
yeah first of all I'm very sad to hear
about the passing of your parents at
such a young age that said however I
think you're really thinking ahead
that's very smart 2020 $1,000 you want
to put that to work I prefer these days
using ETFs exchange traded funds and
here's why these days most online
brokers will let you set up an account
no fees which is fantastic because we
really want to reduce our fees if we can
so you set up one of those and then you
why are in the 21,000 and if you're you
know you're young or 21 so generally
speaking the older you get the more you
want to put in more conservative
investments like fixed income like bonds
something like that or these you know
these guaranteed certificates of deposit
which aren't great in my view because
you're only making about 2% but that's
not bad if you're just saving money but
you can get ETFs that are basically a
basket a very short-term government
bonds that yield about 1.9 to 2.1
percent so the key is all of these
services provide you with information
about which ETS to buy I like ETF's
they're transparent they're low fee
they're very liquid you can buy and sell
them so I would buy some you know
something like the SP Y which is the
entire market it's very inexpensive if
you get the whole you know Standard &
Poor's 500 stocks that make up the
largest market cap companies in the
world basically and then maybe you get
50 percent in that and then another 40
percent in a couple of ETFs that are
just short duration government bonds and
short duration corporate credits again
these are available and you I always say
ask an advisor because you're going to
get one for free on these online
services you can just just text them and
they'll give you an
say look I want to be sort of 50% in
equities inexpensive ETFs and maybe 40%
in short duration government bonds and
short duration corporate debt investment
grade that's triple B and then 10% cash
and most of these provide a cash account
to which has yield so then all the
money's going to work
it'll be volatile stocks will go up and
down but over time because Emily are so
young I think you probably you know an
average from the past you're gonna make
6 7% a year on average on the equities
and maybe 2 or 3% on the debt and it'll
grow and it'll be ready for you when you
retire and don't forget to add to it you
got to add to it take 10% of your
salaries what I always say thank you for
that one let's go to our next question
thanks mr. wonderful for taking my
question the greatest technical
innovations have usually been met with
fierce opposition from large corporate
competitive interests innovators like
Nikola Tesla come to mind what is your
advice to innovators on how to confront
or avoid similar opposition so
innovation is a disruption and so
whenever you have a Tesla or somebody
that's trying to change the world going
to all-electric cars you're going to
piss somebody off because maybe you're
building gas driven cars or maybe you're
already existing industry disruption is
always met with resistance that always
happens but that's how we advance I mean
it's really great when things keep
moving forward and I think I owned a
Tesla now I was very skeptical my son
works at Tesla's and in turn there so
he's beginning to learn his craft he's
very interested in how the future is
gonna look is you sound like you are my
advice to people that want to be
Mavericks is put your blinders on focus
on what you want to achieve and don't
listen to all the noise that noise is
horrific and just really really bad and
it's always going to be eating at you
but you've got to stay focused on the
goal
I was taught that years ago by a mentor
and it's absolutely true stay focused
don't let distractors bother you don't
let them get you down and invariably
you're going to be kicked to the ground
as a maverick or an entrepreneur or
anybody who's trying to achieve their
own freedom but you got to get up and
keep going
that's my advice great question though I
like that a lot these are very
thoughtful questions it's terrific
let's see we got next hello mr.
wonderful my name is Justin and I'm 26
years old one year ago I started a
construction and development company
with no loans or investors so far has
done very well and just in the last six
months we have had 1.5 million dollars
in revenue with well over $200,000 in
net profit after paying myself we have
incredible growth slotted for next year
based on signed contracts my issue is
I'm feeling guilty paying myself so
early in the company life after hearing
the sharks and other entrepreneurs
stories I just want your opinion on when
it is okay to start giving yourself a
salary thanks mr. wonderful Justin your
own rock star my friend good for you
that's absolutely spectacular that's
what it takes the guts to get out there
and start really excited for you now
look I got some advice here okay number
one there's nothing wrong with paying
yourself particularly from what I'm
listening to you can afford it but the
key to that is you're taking it out of
the company and investing it in
something else that's completely
different that Justin is the concept of
diversification so you put it into an
ETF where you put it into the stock
market you put it into bonds but it has
nothing to do with your construction
business because what you find in life
is which would get too concentrated and
you leave all the money in the business
and something happens and believe me in
life poop what happens you're wiped out
you don't want that to happen you're
starting your diversification now so
let's say you pull out of 50,000
basically have to live off it but if you
could keep 10% or 15% of what you're
taking out and invest it it's something
completely different like a portfolio of
stocks and bonds that's how you get
wealthy long term but I love that
entrepreneurial spirit you are a rock
star
absolutely fantastic clearly you're very
focused on what you're doing and many
others can learn from what Justin just
said I mean he's focused on business and
he did it without any
as cash you 100 sell your business
spectacular you know it makes me feel
great to hear that kind of thing
and for all of the others of you are
listening you got to be adjustment if
you really have that entrepreneurial
spirit in your heart you go and become a
Justin it absolutely great I love that
one
Thank You Justin terrific a brief
musical interlude
[Music]
[Music]
I hope you get what you need with mr.
wonderful because I'm answering
questions let's go to Gavin here
hey mr. wonderful I'm 16 years old and
I'm an aspiring entrepreneur and I think
I have a good idea for a tech startup
but the problem is that I don't not a
code I'm afraid that the need to hire
developers will push away all potential
investors should I take the time to
learn code over the next couple years or
should I go ahead and start anyways
thank you any response would be
appreciated Gavin you don't have to be a
coder to be an entrepreneur the key is
you've got to find coders are gonna work
with you and for you you're doing a
start-up find a great coder because look
it's an extreme talent you know if
you're good at coding you're good at
coding if you're good as an entrepreneur
good as a manager you're good at that
that sounds like what you are so you
have a vision for a business you find a
great coder to lead the team and you
give that person that man or woman's
some equity they become effectively your
partner if they have a they believe in
your vision that's how all the great
companies were started that's how Steve
Jobs started Apple think about it found
a fantastic engineer and worked with
them the two of them built that business
to the largest company on earth today
look there's nothing wrong with with not
being a coder and if you're probably not
going to be able to it's kind of like a
half something you were born with you
really have to have an unusual mind to
be a coder that's what I've learned but
I've hired hundreds of coders in my day
at the Learning Company we used to
create software I was a marketing person
and I have to have coders to make reader
rabbits Carmen Sandiego is and products
like that you have to understand what
you're good at and focus on that and I
think it sounds like you're gonna be
terrific
as a manager anyways enjoy that journey
great question
[Music]